love going live liquid life I think
we're live we're live we're live this is
awesome okay hello everyone and welcome
to run table de stream team this is
where we talk to amazing content
creators and their journeys where they
are today well today we're doing a
little bit something different well - a
couple of different things one you can
see all three of us we're trying a
different way of kind of doing the stuff
and we're using zoom not gonna lie
and we're also this is the stuck inside
edition because everyone is just stuck
inside can't leave our houses so I just
wanted to talk to everybody and see how
everybody who's been doing and enjoying
their quarantine and talked to you know
see how everything's been and then
starting next week we already have some
guests lined up to come back and I
finally have my internet connection
fixed so hopefully with some luck we
don't have any any kickoffs or anything
like that so anyway we have L + MJ here
so MJ why don't you tell us first so you
know what's going on what's new all the
monsterschool
my sleep schedules my stuff because I've
been playing too many games I've been
streaming a little bit haven't really
left the house too much but it's been
playing everything new doom final
fantasy MLB went back can be farcry new
dawn picked up a couple games on the
Xbox sale and yeah nice and micelle how
about yourself you can't get one quiet a
little bit there will your mic down is
it connected to your other mic oh no on
your headset try pulling your headset
one down there it is yeah but that's not
what I wanted Oh see always we're always
having technical difficulties it's not
bad
like super easy like watch this
narrative Eddie oh right hot fire that's
good I was gonna say yeah so just
working which you know we're still
having our sprints and everything
because I work at a company where
everybody can work remotely with no
problem and kids are out so that's
awesome and yeah just trying to limit
how much I go out yeah you know as much
as I can but work is still they still
want us to work daily Oh in the office
in the office which is kind of a little
weird but they the niceness about it is
that like a lot of the management staff
what kind of this like yeah that's let's
make a rotation schedule so we have
people going in for a week and then out
for a week and for a week out for a week
but being I'm part of IT I'm the only IT
guy for the site they kind of want me to
be there like every every week so I'm
like listen I'm like that doesn't work
for me so what can we do to make that
better and we're actually doing like me
and for a couple of days out for a
couple of days and for a couple days out
for a couple days so it kind of works
out that I'm like almost like we're
rotation so I'm in the office for a day
or two out for a day or two so that's
cool yeah I took last Friday off because
I had been going since before this all
started and cuz I was actually sick
right before everybody was like oh my
god we need to be you know aware of all
this
so I was at home before that working and
then they let the kids out and I just
needed a break it was too much you know
I'm here by myself I don't have any
family here and stuff so I was just like
all right I need a day break where I
didn't sleep yeah yeah yeah I actually
got a sinus infection right before this
all start yeah so we both had it right
I was just like this is horrible and
then like I called to make a doctor's
appointment and the doctors wouldn't
even let me go into the office never
like you sir can talk to me over the
phone and we could figure out what we
can do they ended up sending me some
stuff so some meds I was lucky but I'm
just like yeah because it started
hitting you guys up there quicker or bad
over here and we're required because of
us working in construction like some
people have to be working like on top of
other people we have to have full face
shields with our masks on underneath and
glasses so it's like this is insane but
right it's like it's for our efforts for
our benefit so it's been good yeah so so
so MJ what about you have you been
having to deal with the same stuff that
we have you pretty much and staying at
home haven't really been going out and
streaming with somebody who's typing in
the chat right now psycho static yeah
I've been playing some Monopoly and some
you know with him and a couple other
people a little bit of far cry and yeah
I've been it's actually weird because
we've been like the travel cuz my
travels it's an hour-and-a-half travel
for me to go to the office to and from
so now if I have to go tuned from the
office it's 45 minutes there's no
traffic on the road so I'm like
literally like flying going 70 and 80
and so I'm getting all that time back
and then I'm getting the time that I
don't have to travel so it's like I can
stay up a little later so I could stream
a little later and then like I could
start streaming a little earlier because
I'm home a little earlier had like so
it's like it's been nice I can kind of
like finesses it a little bit so it
works out really well have you guys been
like doing stuff like that staying up
too late
gaming too too much because I have to do
other stuff so it's a little harder for
me sleep schedule so someone's gonna be
the responsible one
that word about the low is the little
puppy
jumpin IJ well no he's fine now he's not
a puppy but he's small everyone thinks
he's a puppy everyone inabilities he's
not young but he's still you know very
active and everything my girl dog who's
I guess 11 now she's an [ __ ] there's
always one animal that you have that's
always that way right yeah she she like
bit the crap out of me over the weekend
not this week in the last weekend
because I needed a groomer and like I
actually give her a tranquilizer okay
oh wow to groom her and she still bit
the crap out of me so our guinea pigs is
actually yeah she she actually got sick
with pneumonia and it's like one of
those things are like oh this stuff
could only happen to us thankfully like
we you were giving her meds and she's
feeling better and stuff and when we
give her meds now now she doesn't she
doesn't want any part of it like she's
bitten my arm yeah I got a couple I got
a couple scratches and stuff on my arm
and stuff like that but it's like she's
really really good and I and I love her
to death but like oh man I'm like I'm
just trying to help you I'm just trying
to make you a better Pig right yeah I
know like I'm gonna shake you so you
know I love you yeah so what games have
you been playing so Call of Duty I'm
playing war zone and the regular
multiplayer my finished Wolfenstein
Youngblood because I only had one the
last part to finish and we hadn't done
it in forever I also started playing a
way out with my dad because he's in
California and I was just looking for
something to play together and then
we've been playing see a team's a lot of
see if these actually yeah it's it's
funny it's I want it's funny that you
said that you're like playing with your
dad
do you um remember when we had mad queen
on and she was talking about how city of
heroes came back yeah I thought of
catching one of her streams with her
playing with her dad yes the funniest
thing I've seen in a while yeah cuz she
was like well dad I'm gonna play as his
character no you shouldn't you're
horrible with that you should play with
this one like thanks thanks dad
Dex I appreciate it no why would be like
my dad like does not get how he's
supposed to be moving or he wants he
plays and he wants to play but I swear
he like loses all common sense when he
starts to like he doesn't get where he's
supposed to go I don't know
Mita Medina da ya ya play - that was
pretty good man Madonna its but it's
just like until dawn okay yeah there's
not really much combat or anything like
that old dialogue grant yep
so that's something else if you wanted
to play with them I think you're both
ought to have your own individualized
copies though mm-hmm so that's that's
pretty cool
so what did you guys think of war zone
oh yeah what I thought that yeah yes I
have what's your thoughts well I mean I
enjoy it I've been decent at it I mean I
was playing solos two days ago at like
1:00 in the morning and I dropped 13
kills and came in third because so I
mean I was doing pretty good then and
then I've been playing a couple games
with psycho and the chat yeah well I
mean I enjoy it I mean it's free I mean
if people see Call of Duty they don't
want to pay $60 for it right thank you
so what is totally free
yeah we're sons free no I didn't know
that mm-hmm you know um I got the dog so
you can SiC your dog on people as you're
finishing moves oh yeah I haven't done
it yet um it was funny though because
when we were playing someone did it to
lady and she like
very loudly screamed out you know as
soon as the dog he's just like you know
runs upon you and attacks you but yeah
so I can't wait to do this to somebody
excuse me for about you I I haven't
played war zone I've been watching a lot
of people stream it and a lot of people
play it and it for me I feel like it's
too fast paced oh my god you're crazy I
don't know what's the right play because
this is slow compared to Eric's really
so I guess it's because I'm kind of more
used to slower paced games now like like
when I was playing titanfall uh I loved
titanfall when you got that when you're
playing you got your mech you blow stuff
up but like once once you were like free
running and you were in your like person
state it was just it was too much it was
just like I'm like I can't do this
anymore people are running past me and
night for me in the back yeah yeah no
you gotta just get in there and like
move and then like apex will be slow
like it won't be that fast like I don't
know I I have to start playing some be
ours I guess because I I don't normally
play be ours but like I try I think the
less PR that I tried was
fortnight and that was like yes I
actually I did get into BR and I can't
really discuss it um scheme scavengers I
ended up playing that but I'm under NDA
for that that was interesting
that's a that was actually I think is
gonna be a very very good BR once it's
fully evolved and completed so that's
something that I would say definitely
people should keep an eye out for
scavengers um that was pretty good so
but yeah yeah
so so what are the what other games are
you playing I'm Ju
playing uno and stuff like that monopoly
um I beat doom yeah little bit of MLB I
got Final Fantasy 7 remake yeah and then
what did you say your gripe was before
about fun Fantasy 7 what what did you
say your gripe was oh I couldn't find
the physical copy anymore he wanted the
physical copy and then yeah because the
difference is what because it takes up
more storage if you get a digital
vegetables like 90 gigs and then I think
physical was like 70 kind of weird I
mean he doesn't have what do you don't
have a tournament they're all hooked up
with my xbox ok yeah it's on PlayStation
yeah yeah and on PlayStation that's
gonna suck downloading 2 or something
well they throttled I guess the yeah cuz
that stops a 500 gigabyte that's why so
I mean that probably has to something
unless he like I'm not saying that I'm
saying
why would PlayStation feel the need to
because their crap will probably break
into didn't like they will probably have
like way more issues like that's the
only reason why they would do that like
there's no other reason you know and I
know ity is there's no other reason for
them the throttle enlists they
anticipated some issues though that the
the cables burn up problem yeah they
probably have to throw it like it have
you guys that was the other thing have
you guys noticed your home areas have
you have they been throttling you guys
at your home well I don't know what it
is but lately we've been getting kicked
off the internet more often but I think
that's just because so many people were
on it and I'm an apartment building you
know so you have like way more people
like on it so yeah we it was it was
actually really interesting because
well the reason why we haven't had a
show on for so long was because my
internet has got to poop literally it's
gone to poop and I finally when this
whole fiasco happens with the quarantine
I ended up getting on the phone with my
internet service provider and I said hey
you guys listen we need to we got to fix
this this is going on too long and the
end result was that these guys said all
right fine we'll come out we'll take a
look at it
and it was like two weeks until they can
come out I was like you got to be
kidding me it's two weeks they finally
come out when the guy comes here it's
not even a regular service provider
directly from the company it was like a
contractor so they had to the contractor
guy to come to your house and then when
the guy came here he goes we're not
allowed to come into your home we could
only do things outside your house and I
was like okay that's perfectly fine my
parents don't want you in my house
anyway but the guy ended up rerunning
the line on the outside and everything
and everything was fine after that but
thankfully but there's I've noticed that
everything has been good here as a whole
um but other neighbors around the area
have been saying that they feel like
it's been getting slow so I think I
think that people are getting a little
throttled look where people are living
because of this whole situation being
stuck inside so so yeah you got have you
guys been increasing your stream times a
little bit or elevated yes I was but for
me I I usually stream around the same
time because I try to give myself time
after I get done working to kind of like
decompress and everything since you know
you don't get that drive home and stuff
like that that time to decompress from
work and so I usually stream at the same
time and for two hours so I usually go
for my 8:00 to 10:00 7:00 to 10:00
something like that which is like what I
was normally doing uh-huh but I've ever
seen MJ on
I never see empty on either he's singing
I'm streaming again and I'm whole let's
see um usually it's at night time for my
9:00 o'clock until usually midnight yeah
we're dead by then no I'm kidding um so
how has it been for you since you've
been home with the whole college
situation since it's been like it's con
sucks yeah I just I don't know I don't
like having to teach myself statistics
which kind of makes things pretty hard
and then also I kind of have to teach
myself a unity well that's kind of you
know but it's hard it's like my first
time programming with unity - mm-hmm
because I mean I'm supposed to have like
a teacher there since the classrooms
only like 12 people and he's supposed to
help us if we're confused and we don't
have that so after they create this ball
game and then submit it by May 1st
so I'm like halfway done but I don't
like I don't know unities it's kind of
hard to learn by yourself
personally and I could imagine a lot of
the game developers when we see them at
PAX they they ended up saying that's
that's what almost all their games are
in is unity now yeah which Corey or you
or use a whole unity it's it's very
surprising and I think that unity if you
learn it you'll be in so much better
shape to be able to do whatever you want
to do because everyone pretty much
requires it yeah that's what my teacher
is saying
you naughty using unity it's like a 75%
boost your application if you're
applying for a video game developer yeah
they don't to teach you anything yeah
well like I I learned VB and Java right
not even not even visual basic or C
sharp or any of those just regular
visual basicnet and now if I have to
anything or if I have to end up coding
anything it's like it's very difficult
because most of the stuff is foreign I
don't understand concepts but not much
more than that yeah that's kind of where
I am like I can like understand for the
most part what's going on with Java and
stuff but what I do mainly for my job is
I use a lot of sequel oh really yeah I
don't necessarily have the cold per se
but like I don't know I guess I'm coding
I'm not like really writing programs as
far as like I'm coding procedures no but
I'm not the dev you know what I mean
like I'm the BA so like I need to be
able to read it in to pull stuff and to
write some stuff but then the devs do it
and they like do like crazy stuff with
it mm-hmm but I'm getting better like
way better yeah how have you guys been
connecting with like family and stuff
since since everything's going on based
on Simon
yeah oh yeah well MJ's like you're at
home right well your even what do you do
with your fraternity brothers yeah going
to the bathroom what I said you going
into the bathroom with the zoom call now
no nobody's done it yet nope that's
weird like I know like my wife she's
been she's been teaching and stuff like
that and like there's been so there's
been some questionable situations what
these kids have been doing mm-hmm and
it's like like that's actually like
Salaam hey guys you're not supposed to
be doing that that's not a good idea and
that's kind of weird where they have to
go you know you got to think about that
for a moment right it's like
that's fantastic but yeah like for us
we've been like so we did we did Easter
um by having her parents we invited her
parents over and they literally sat on
the other side of a table outside how we
sat on the other side of the table just
to talk to him for a little bit for like
a half hour and then they went home and
then my wife ended up going over there
to see them and they lit really like
they sat in their cars like six feet
apart like sitting on the tailgate
stalking yeah because like we want to
try to keep the keep communications open
because they're not very tech savvy okay
yeah and then like my niece like I want
to see her more often like my brother
and sister-in-law I could talk to them
on the phone but like my niece said I
could want to physically see and I've
done the way that I'm able to do that is
by doing face sound like you were doing
right and I sometimes there are times
kind of just don't coincide because my
sister-in-law is now turned into a
teacher essentially for her so she's got
our on the schedule and everything like
just like regular school and going
through everything so it's been it's
been a little little difficult for for
them as a whole like what I know about
it yeah what how has it been going for
you because of your because of your kid
I told you that's why I took off Friday
because I was just like enough like oh
oh no are they on spring they're on
spring break now or on spring break last
week but oh like they you know they're
out for the year they've already told
them that they're out for the year also
they're done yeah
and they still haven't like come up with
like they haven't reported any type of
real plan that's - like how they're
gonna learn so I just signed it for
education comm and I'm keeping going
with what they were doing before I mean
what else can we do right yeah that's
that's crazy like I didn't I didn't
realize that well when does your school
normally done May June okay
yeah cuz they they go to usually the end
of June here okay so I mean they're they
with my wife school specifically they
have often this week okay and half of
last week mm-hmm so like when this whole
situation could have happened they kind
of transitioned into like the Friday
before the whole day cut they were like
guys this is what you need to do this is
what you have to do with the computer G
go blah blah blah blah blah that Monday
all the teachers had one day to prep you
say they went and to talking to their
specific students and then after that
they were just like boom right back it's
a class schedule that Wednesday and then
they went like a full week two weeks
like that mm-hmm and now they're on
spring break which is kind of nice
because the amount of preparation that
the teachers are doing for their kids is
it's so much more so I have to like
applaud them and commend all the
teachers and to try to still teach kids
with going through the computers because
there's I wouldn't be able to do it I'd
want to like strangle somebody through
the computer yeah out here it seems like
they did that for middle school in high
school but for the elementary they
didn't oh I don't know maybe they
figured they'll be okay a lot of states
in the South they're telling this the
kids cuz they don't have the
infrastructure down there yet they have
to redo 12th grade death to redo another
year of school I know they're pissed
yeah yeah how would you feel about that
MJ I feel like your your class semesters
not gonna count you got to redo it no
pissed I know
ours is pass/fail oh that's how you guys
do it yes well did they change that or
is it open pass well at first it was
just regular and then they just emailed
us like two weeks ago saying there's
gonna be searched a pass/fail oh wow
[Music]
that's interesting
yep
anything else that's new deciding going
on watch trolls Oh had there was a
patrols mom musical or something I mean
the movie is like a musical essentially
but you know they had they had a release
directly into your house alright so it
didn't release in theaters you're able
to just buy it at your house on release
day
Vudu and and amazon.com mmm right so we
played 20 bucks to rent it for the
weekend 20 bucks to rent to get rights
to rent for the weekend Wow
yeah I was pretty happy about it I mean
it was a good movie I tried to watch it
a couple of times I made her watch it
like three times we're getting our
money's worth yeah but she like I'm
complaining about it she's like well
that's like the same price you would pay
for us to go to the theater and I'm like
shut up such a rational right gonna be
pissed about this 20 bucks here we
actually we saw aa word mm-hmm on Disney
Plus that was really good oh yeah we saw
it in theaters here oh yeah oh my we see
every Disney movie well if girls listen
um we're gonna watch on more time I'm
like okay she's like Chris Pratt is one
of the voices I'm like I'm in yeah and
spider-man is with Tom Holland mm-hmm
probably two of my favorite actors right
now yeah see he didn't read it really
well for people that I don't think I've
done any voice acting before I know
Chris Pratt has done voice acting yes
yeah and so has Tom Holland the movie
what's Will Smith the animated movie all
the bird one he was the little young
scientists
but and I think he did fine like I don't
think he was horrible but people think
he's horrible apparently but I think
people just don't like them come on yeah
Tom how long though he single-handedly
received the spider-man franchise he
didn't do that there are writers in
everybody else did that well yes yes
they did they did that but when they did
the merger they really I said originally
it's done and Tom Holland apparently got
on the phone with people I was like
listen you don't you're doing me dirty
alright so yeah because they he knows
that movie was suck if Marvel wasn't
helping to make the next one yeah yeah
what's up mostly Martina how's it going
man so yeah we have but we ended up
seeing onward we've like my wife has
been watching lots of shits Creek oh my
god I'm already like done with it though
so but I might watch the last season
over cuz I didn't really pay too much
yes no no this season coming up is gonna
be the last season sorry thank think I'm
right but I've been watching a black
lightning so I think I'm done with that
for on Netflix how how was it it's good
so I didn't like the first season as
much but I just talked to Matt Queen the
other day and she really liked the first
season which was hilarious and I thought
it got better but she said she number
one didn't like two but like three but
three was by far the best season because
like one of them one of the characters
becomes like basically the Phoenix type
of character yeah so they like have you
seen are you up-to-date on like arrow
flash the reverse no no yeah I don't I
haven't really watched any of the cw-16
since Smallville and this is probably
like my first time getting back into
like a DC series I will I will tell you
that
Eero mm-hmm totally got me hooked and
then here there it's really good and
then what I ended up doing was once I
started watching arrow and then started
watching everything else since the
session as it came out so then I was
started to watch like cuz like what ends
up happening is there's so many
crossover episodes so like you'll be
like watching arrow and it's like to do
and the next thing you know like um the
flash is there and he's like you know
thanks for helping me out over in stars
star city but I'm like what
and so then like I had to start watching
arrow and it's like Oliver went there
because of a situation and that ends up
like interweaving into the arrow verse
and then something ends up happening
there what ends up going into the next
one and I was just like oh my god I was
like this is crazy
I just did that so so it's literally
like everything will start interweaving
left and right so I started watching all
of them together and I know that they
started adding black lightning in and I
haven't I haven't seen it yet I have to
kind of figure out where that is
yeah and the crossovers the crossover
episodes hands down are amazing I
haven't seen yes so like I kind of felt
like I wanted to go because go and watch
the last one I guess it's like the
multiverse type one yeah right
yeah but it's it's there's so much
build-up and there's so much character
development that happens way before that
that I mean if you want to watch it by
all means watch it but it goes across
all of the episode all I think six
different show mm-hmm all shows because
it also hits bat girl because they end
up bringing her character into it and
you're back here alright the new Batgirl
what's her name Rubirosa thing is she's
so like her they bring her in their
black lightning in they bring the arrow
they bring the Supergirl they bring them
all in and it's supposed to be so good
and I stopped to watch it I'm so I'm so
behind on it but because there's so much
yeah I'll probably end up just watching
this do it
I watched uh what's name - what's it so
I mean that movie Harley Quinn or birds
of prey how was it you know I liked it I
mean Harley Quinn is one of my favorite
characters from DC and I think that
margot robbie really pleased her well
yes yes she does a fantastic Harley
Quinn y'all what's up cog man thanks
Ryan
you know stopping and saying what's up
you like the setup it's nice and clean
maybe maybe it'll make your life a
little easier the future we'll talk
later so yeah so what's a cocktail in
completely got my train of thought out
of whack Oh birds of prey did you ever
see the original birds of prey the TV
show no but you know what was funny is
that like I'm turning my kid into such a
nerd that I got her to watch the
directors credits you know the director
version where they like you know talk
about the movie as they're watching the
movie yeah and so we're watching it and
they're like you know going back to the
original comic and stuff like that
showing you scenes and stuff from it to
like show you where they took to do the
movie so that was pretty cool that's
really cool yeah cuz the the whole the
whole original TV show I thought it was
a it wasn't great it's an amazing
concept it was like you know they could
they could do so much more and that's
what that's why I want to see birds of
prey I like I think I'm gonna have to
buy a whole bunch of movies you just
been watching some binge watched some
movies because like I think Netflix
right now for me I just went on
so I shoot myself yeah it's like there's
only so much Netflix and only someone
truly I can watch because we've were
we're like almost out of everything I
almost caught up on everything
yeah they need it like Netflix needs to
put out a movie like cuz all they have a
series right now
it's just like okay like I'm done with
this
although did you see that they did put
out the movie um coffee and cream no
okay I think it's coffee and Korean
alright what about um Jay have you being
able to watch the TV at all I haven't
really watched him too much anything
just YouTube yep mm-hmm
okay so look it up coffee and cream oh I
think you're going to talk about it I
mean I am but you need to see what I'm
talking about first and then I'll tell
you oh my god is this yes so it's Ed
Helms taraji P Henson and whoever this
little kid is and basically they're a
couple or a starting-off couple and the
son Mike hates him and tries to get him
got by gangsters basically just not
funny so it's pretty hilarious and the
he curses the little kid curses like
crazy you know we should do we should
end up you know it's funny I gotta watch
it again it's pretty hilarious to do
watch party and throw it up stopped in
Kingdom decided to stop in this is cool
a buddy cop type of film that that's
cool we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
have to do watch party yes funny well if
it was to set something up and do it I
thought that is a good plan that was
good plan so so anyhow I just wanted to
you know just want to you know catch up
with you guys cuz it's it's been a day
and a half and everyone's been stuck
inside and driving driving ourselves
crazy and I know Elle's like me work and
probably look at it looking at four
walls and from home so things me proud
to may have been playing a lot of
impasse oh really
what what have you been playing in game
pass The Witcher and a little bit of a
journey to savage
which is that one um
I spy a studio that uh stadia just
acquired it's kind of like a type of
game sort of I don't know kind of like
fallout yeah interesting looks pretty
cool whoa I meant to say I finished
gears 5 I'm suited finally hmm here's
the question is did you finish it before
or after cog cuz really I just finished
it like last week oh then you finish it
after cog yeah cuz like he literally was
like I tried to do but I couldn't do it
I had to have my friends help me
well it wasn't really like I needed help
I just needed
Tod's I needed a friend to play with
like I didn't want to play with ya so I
did it with Cherise pretty quickly nice
and have you played it to the end I
haven't played it I haven't played gears
at all I have to start downloading and
start playing more games it's just it's
I have to figure out a way to get more
time to play or I should say were the
first game exactly it's on look what
King said frogs frauded the truth I know
I know I tried the lake what are the
challenges I've been trying to build my
streaming community so I've been kind of
focusing solely on believe it or not
Warcraft and escape from tarkov
and since I've gotten my internet
connection fixed mm-hmm I've actually
seen a substantial growth like an like
an upward like if you look at my actual
charts actually going up so it's almost
like I don't want to what's the code I
don't want to stop it cuz I don't want
to like
that again because I give before it like
kind of like plateaued because it you
know how it is when you're when you're
streaming you don't want to be playing
and then all of a sudden the Internet
like you didn't act our eyes like nobody
wants to watch that so like I ended up
without beginning days where I'd be
getting full streams no problem great
next day I would be good for 15 minutes
or die come back up be good for 15
minutes die come back up and nobody
nobody wants to see that
and King I have actually believe it or
not not played the division that much I
think I've played the division maybe
three times I may be played like six
eight hours maybe of division in the
past month which for me is actually not
that much so believe me I haven't been
playing the division Island journey you
play this multiplayer oh that's
interesting
yeah it's co-op cute wants to know what
headset is the Castros masters a little
meeseeks guys on the side well there's
the a 40's yes a forties fifties the
owners why don't have the eight fifties
is because like I have my whole setup
here and stuff and I was having problems
with the 2.4 ban Webster it's typically
on oh yeah yeah the wireless they run
off of 2.4 or something like that I
think it's two point four hours to
bluetooth but it basically I have too
much stuff going on here big no always
messes it so once I got the a 40's and
plug directly into my PC I haven't had
an issue I've also been playing a lot of
Borderlands I beat every dlc LOL is not
a fan of the world lands clearly I don't
like it I played it I was just like this
is doom suits I plead I played and
completed the first Borderlands
right mm-hmm and when we came back from
pax right before Borderlands 3 came out
not this year the year before with MJ
when he was there with us they gave us
all the DLC everything for Borderlands I
started playing I said let's do it and
then I just found myself doing this you
might fall asleep I was like more action
you should do the D&D DLC for tiny
Tina's attack on Dragon keep on
Borderlands 2 that's the best one you're
a D&D guy right I am a GED guy I was
just like oh man I might be my teen
decroux actually we had to put
everything on hold for a couple of for a
couple of weeks because of everything
going on too because it was I feel like
we need to we got to kind of get
ourselves together mentally and
physically you didn't be able to start
to in D&D again because some of the
people in the group they have you know
personal situations that kind of got
thrown in so we were like oh wait for
that also been playing Animal Crossing
I've been playing that he hates that
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo look I always
post the little oh yes the little
pictures whenever you tweet out and you
get really mad okay okay thanks man for
stopping by I appreciate it have a good
night enjoy your day at work and yes and
yes mostly Martine Martinez has been
he's been in my channel and he sees me
playing sour cough because that that
games each rental and rush a lot of the
twitch streamers for talk I would start
by wearing heart monitors so you can
actually you can see you can actually
see what happens when they start playing
because the adrenaline rush you get when
you're playing is unlike any other night
King unlike any other like my heartbeat
goes so fast
wanna hear gunshots you'll actually see
me duck like I'm really gonna get hit by
bullets in from a video game
it's intense it's crazy oh that's really
not but going back to the animal
crossing I've been watching people play
animal crossing it looks really cool it
looks fun it's just I just I don't I
don't understand I don't understand it I
mean did you ever play like The Sims or
anything like that I played The Sims
yeah kind of like the Sims
kind of kind of you should give it a try
No
are you by a switch and I'll buy the
game how about that oh my god oh wait no
it's impossible to find one right now
yeah I heard there's shortages did you
hear did you listen to my podcast we
talked about Cooking Mama no they came
out with Cooking Mama right and I've
guessed like within a week they had to
pull it off the shelves and take it off
of the eShop because basically they've
determined first it was a rumor that
they were mining Bitcoin and it was
overheating your switch but then they
determined that it wasn't that it was
that they're mining Bitcoin the code was
just really crappy and the people who
own the IP knew the code was crappy and
said don't put it out but the publisher
still put it out so now that people who
own the IP are suing this publisher and
Nintendo just took it off so can't find
it anywhere anymore whoa
so if you go to Amazon you'll see it
like it'll say being sold by these
retailers or these sellers just people
selling it for like 65 bucks
Jesus yeah they're selling it for more
but apparently it might overheat your
foot so why even gent it crazy right
that was intense
crazy just crazy and I was gonna buy it
too cuz it's cooking mama so I was gonna
get it for my kid I I will tell you that
is the first game that I played with my
niece
yep
with the Wii I was like you gotta put
the controller like this okay right yeah
same same thing yeah one of the first
games I play with her yeah it's
fantastic I love it but anyhow do you
have any other guys have any other news
oh no no I guess we uh I guess we'll do
our outro so I guess so uh MJ what
starts off find me on Twitter and
Instagram
baby MJ can find me on Twitch at MJ's a
boss so I'll be live tonight at 11:00
the psycho playing some Far Cry primal
and then my snapchat is beat one on one
yeah I have one question for you do you
have a tick tock no why don't you have a
tick tock did you guys see Tiger king I
heard ho video never mind a man that
makes us see okay my wife is addicted to
tick tock videos now yeah so every time
I see a tick tock video I think of you
cuz I figured that one of these days I'm
gonna roll through check top I see a
video of you you know something
ridiculous oh no no no L work we find
you um elbow do 2:08 on Twitter and
everything else you can find me on mixer
Tuesday through Friday 7:00 to 8:00 p.m.
until I feel like getting off so I and
you guys know me it is ass now though
that is SNA ly geo on all channels and
everything that is on Twitch Instagram
Twitter yeah pretty much that's it
that's pretty much everything and
discord if you're looking for me and
discord it's on there under the ILP
discord if you ever need me for anything
so I will just say thanks guys for you
know come on stop
then say hello hanging out for a little
bit I know that we were all kind of you
know try to get our grooves back on
we'll get the schedule back we already
have some amazing guests scheduled so
I've actually spoke to the guys from
wicked good games and we're gonna do a
little expose if you will on them we're
gonna have each of them on once per week
and then we're gonna have all of them
together on the last episode so first so
it's gonna be a couple of weeks of the
of the guys and they are hilarious if
you guys listen to their podcast
it is funny as heck and we're gonna be
having those guys starting next week go
check out the iron Lords podcast they
are you know a another part of our
channel here if you guys am or the game
and end lords of gaming calm lose games
net I'm sorry
if you check us out for all of our news
articles there we have some great
articles that have been says the best
articles out there he's negative be
careful on my screen but I'll put on the
channel that way I was down here for me
oh this is gonna be fun it looks like
you're holding us up looks like you're
like bench pressing us both closer
together
we're gonna have to mess around that
stuff but anyway um so then yes and then
if you guys have any questions or
anything if you want to ask us you can
always email us a roundtable stream team
at gmail.com our twitter is a table
stream go ahead and follow us there so
you can see when things are gonna be
going on who's new what's gonna happen
when we get new stuff coming on addict
what is going on buddy how you doing
nice and I've seen you stop by girly
appreciate your support appreciate you
and we're gonna have our this all
converted over to our podcast platforms
you know I choose Spotify SoundCloud all
that fun stuff
tune in google podcasts all those fun
things and like I said remember go check
out I was podcast on Sundays and before
we go L what about your podcast yep you
can find me on Saturday mornings at
twelve Eastern 9 a.m. Pacific on growing
my gaming channel on YouTube go check
those ladies out they are great they're
funny and they are brilliant and they
will really enlighten you guys so you
get the ladies on Sun on Saturday and
you get the guys at the IOP TM Sunday so
you get both you know amazing podcast in
a row and and once again thank you
everybody for hanging out and I'm happy
that this kind of this kind of worked
pretty good course out really nicely so
remember everyone dream big and keep
gaming and we will see everyone next
week thanks again everyone have it going
everyone wrong Mouse